white police have arrested an Italian
man after English referee Anthony Taylor
was attacked by Roma fans the official
was hounded by a group of supporters at
Budapest Airport after the Italian
team's defeat by severe in Wednesday's
heated Europa League final
[Applause]
the referee and his family were ushered
into a secure area by airport to
security as members of the crowd yelled
and threw a chair and a bottle in his
Direction Budapest airports a 42 year
old man was apprehended by the police
and criminal proceedings have been
initiated on charges of The Fray
in a statement in the last hour the
Premier League of course this was a UEFA
match but for an English referee the
Premier League have said quote we are
shocked and appalled by the unacceptable
abuse directed at Anthony Taylor and his
family is that they traveled back from
the UEFA Europa League final no one
should have to suffer the inexcusable
Behavior they had to endure yesterday
now the incident comes after Roma
manager Jose Mourinho was seen in these
pictures from sport Italia directing a
string of expletives towards the
officials after the match labeling their
performance a disgrace and speaking to
Sky News earlier former Manchester
United Striker Dr Dublin said the
incident was disgusting and that Jose
Mourinho had a level of responsibility
that shouldn't be a thought process that
we we have to think about referees and
their safety when they're trying to walk
through an airport with their family
just to try and board a plane or to get
from A to B you know you know just a
human being with their family you know
he's he's done his job referees make
mistakes
excuse me referees make mistakes players
make mistakes coaches make mistakes so
you know you never see any of that when
you know players are walking through
lounges and stuff so I think it's just
disgusting I really do
excuse me I think it's really bad you
know you have to do that and I don't
know it's the fans have got to be
embarrassed with themselves surely
trying to get to a referee and his
family
I just think it's disgusting I think
they have to come down on these fans
hard maybe embarrassed about how much
responsibility does Mr Mourinho have in
this you know he was filmed screaming at
Anthony Taylor a day before and then lo
and behold 24 hours later fans of his
Club yeah screaming that's me in the
airport yeah I'll get that I'll get that
and they're always going to be there's
always going to be that look at Mr
Mourinho I think Mr Mourinho may have
shouted at a few other referees as well
I'm not sure if they were attacked
straight after he shouted at them
um then
um at that time so on this occasion for
Mr Anthony Taylor to get attacked by
some fans verbally physically and to
bring it back to Mr Mourinho I think
it's a you know I think he has a part to
play in this Mr Mourinho and I think he
does get that most managers get very
angry when things don't go their way
it's how they deal with it and how they
conduct themselves with that anger and
that frustration
a lot of the times managers do fly off
the handle with referees they always
regret it they always know that they've
been uh they've been wrong in that
situation but I don't think you can pin
this one on Mr Mourinho I think the fans
have got to look at themselves and
hopefully apologize very very soon
because I think their behavior has been
disgusting